the effects are still being felt this
morning of the major weekend storm that
disrupted travelers for millions of
Americans more than 1600 flights were
canceled yesterday and more than 4,000
were delayed more than 200 flights are
already canceled today Kris Van Cleave
is at BWI Thurgood Marshall Airport near
Baltimore where the 31 day partial
government shutdown is also affecting
travel Kris good morning well good
morning more than two million or so
people are expected to fly today here at
BWI the airport has had to close one of
its checkpoints at times we noticed
today all the checkpoints are open but
each checkpoint has several lanes closed
that could be screening passengers this
is in part due to excessive call-outs
increasingly being blamed on the
financial impact of the shutdown
screeners can't afford to come to work
for free any longer and it could get
worse this week as they are positioned
to miss another paycheck on Friday if
this shutdown goes past about Wednesday
nationwide TSA sick calls hit their
highest point Saturday at eight percent
of the workforce still almost 94 percent
of the 1.6 million passengers that flew
Saturday were cleared in 15 minutes or
less but the TSA is experiencing acute
staffing shortages at major airports in
New York Atlanta Chicago and Miami
officers from other airports have been
deployed flown into those cities to
backfill but the TSA says it is
increasingly likely airports across the
country are going to see what we're
seeing at BWI this morning where
security lanes are closed
BWI is saying when it does have to close
a checkpoint it believes the impact will
be minimal the airport is also running a
food drive for affected workers Gail all
right Chris thank you very much